[Musique]
salut à tous ces beaux belieber
bienvenue dans votre podcast préféré ou
comme d'hab je parle de tout ce dont
j'ai envie de parler
donc ces gros producteurs sont venus me
voir et m'ont dit on veut vous écriviez
une comédie romantique sur un couple
homo
un film que même un hétéro pourrait
aimer regarder avec sa petite amie les
gains finaux qui gêne y'a un film que
même un hétéro pourrait aimer est-ce que
je vais me retrouver dans une course
poursuite effrénée tombé subitement
amoureux d'ice cube est ce que je vais
me faire démonter par jason momoa alors
qu'un volcan menace de tout détruire ils
ont dit on veut juste un film qui montre
à tous que les relations entre homos
sont les mêmes que celles entre hétéros
l'amour c'est l'amour elle bord s'est
dit comment l'amour c'est l'amour et ben
non c'est des conneries ça
nos amitiés sont différents je dois
aller à une petite sauterie et vous êtes
trop vieux pour en être vous pouvez
partie nos vies sexuelles sont
différents photo de ton cul j'ai pas de
photo de mon cul je vois ton tu
vois là rien que pour toi quoi il m'a
bloqué nos relations sont différentes
c'est la semaine de sensibilisation à la
bisexualité et des personnes a l'air de
s'en soucier le mois de l'histoire
lesbiennes c'était en mars et personne
n'en a parlé dans bien sûr les
lesbiennes ont un mois et on n'a juste
une semaine je ne veux pas de ces
merdeux riediennes pas de scène ou de
mecs ça fait à baiser et la caméra
s'éloigne comme par hasard
et il faut que xian ravi d'avoir
rencontré moi aussi c'était super
[Musique]
toute ma vie j'ai été fier d'être
quelqu'un d'indépendant
ce qui t'arrive tout d'un coup cet
[ __ ] me fait perdre la tête
qu'est ce que tu cherches un culturiste
décérébrés qui aucun avis sur rien or le
cherche plutôt un gars tout frêle et
fragile qui arrête pas de parler
vote en ligne et tous les deux du cul
c'est ça le problème
le sexe entre gays étaient plus fun
quand il mettait les hétéros mal à
l'aise
de toute façon peu importe je ne suis
pas la bonne personne pour écrire une
comédie romantique
vous vous souvenez des hétéros ça vous
parle ils ont eu leur heure de gloire